la determinación dio finalmente frutos
tras dos días de manifestaciones el
controvertido proyecto de ley fue
retirado por el partido gobernante de
Georgia como partido de gobierno
responsable ante todos los miembros de
la sociedad hemos decidido retirar
incondicionalmente este proyecto de ley
que apoyábamos decenas de miles de
manifestantes denunciaban un proyecto de
ley que consideraban dictado por Moscú
el texto establecía que las
organizaciones que recibieran más del
20% de su financiación del extranjero
estarían obligadas a registrarse como
agentes extranjeros o se enfrentarían a
una multa según las manifestantes esta
medida era similar a la adoptada en
Rusia en 2012 desde entonces ha sido
utilizada por el kremlin para reprimir
las voces críticas con el régimen la
Unión Europea también había expresado su
preocupación y más allá de las fronteras
de Europa Estados Unidos también
presionaba creemos que la continuación
de estas leyes perjudicará las
relaciones de Georgia con sus socios
estratégicos y pondrá en peligro el
futuro de uroatlántico del país el
presidente ucraniano voló lensky también
se había pronunciado al respecto
afirmando que deseaba el éxito
democrático de los manifestantes en
Georgia éxito que han logrado
visiblemente